the average person that knows your name
if they're from the republican side
they think you were framed they think
they uh put you in jail they think they
came after you simply because you were
associating with trump and they think
that that durham investigation that came
out saying the fact that hillary clinton
clinton's dossier was all fake targeting
trying to get you guys to not get
reelected a form of revenge on the other
side if you watch snl
if you watch rachel maddow anderson
cooper don lemon any of these other guys
they would say you had a
connection to russia and putin and
collusion and trump and all of that and
all that's true and that's actually not
why you went away but for the audience
that doesn't know
maybe share with us a little bit about
your background and how it came to the
controversies in 2016. sure i uh
i guess i'd start with i went to
georgetown university graduated from the
law center there as well uh practiced
law for a few years but then
you know got always was interested in
politics i got involved in republican
politics very young my father was mayor
of my hometown
it was a blue-collar town very
democratic town he was a republican uh
first one in his family
uh became a republican because he
disagreed with what fdr did in yalta my
father fought in the world war ii and
was incensed that
that
roosevelt gave away uh central central
europe and uh eastern europe uh for the
and thought we fought for those freedoms
why could he just how could he just give
that to
a communist country uh that was
impactful on him and in talking to him
as i was growing up it became impactful
on me
uh
first campaigns i got really involved in
were uh when i was at georgetown i got
involved with nixon's reelection
campaign uh and then
ford's campaign then
began to be actively involved at the
national level really in ford's campaign
uh served as part of the team that uh
that ran it uh working with uh jim baker
who was his first campaign uh but he and
i became very good friends during that
campaign
uh he's a good man he's a very good man
and uh i talk about in the book i talk
some of uh
uh the stories about those early years
when he was learning uh uh chief of
staffer jerry ford was a very
uh
green behind the years uh
policy guy named dick cheney
it's so
really early on in my career with that
campaign i got to know a number of
people personally and
that who became figures in the
republican party for the next 40 years
uh during the uh
you know after
the
76 campaign got involved in governor
reagan's campaign for president again
was part of the senior team and
after he was elected
roger stone charlie black and i started
a political consulting firm which really
became a lobbying for government affairs
firm as well
and that really began to change the
model or in in the uh you know before
1980 most of the government affairs work
was done by law firms
people were hired law firms were hired
to deal with specific issues that made
legislative issues or regulatory issues
uh we decided to create a different
model we were interested in
international affairs we were interested
in
in
government affairs and so
we thought it was a natural as
grassroots politics was just beginning
and we were on the cutting edge of some
of that to bring some of the campaign
skills into uh
into washington government affairs and
the only republican firm at that time
was a company called timmins and company
bill timmons was legislative director
for uh for nixon in the white house but
he had a very different model his model
was to have
10 or 12
corporate clients
and uh and to only represent that that
group we saw ourselves as a
much different concept uh and uh in the
firm grew became probably one of the
most powerful firms in the washington
scene during the reagan and bush years
during that time we expanded our war
beyond just corporate 500 or to include
a number of countries representing a
number of countries always i should add
uh with u.s foreign policy interests at
heart and always in concert with the
white house notwithstanding what uh
rachel maddow and people like that have
said over the last few years and in fact
if you look at our clients you will see
that we were always involved on in areas
where the foreign policy issues were the
uh were the issues uh affecting those
countries for example in angola
uh we represented jonathan
who was a freedom fighter
for unita and active in uh
in dealing with uh
trying to end the cuban con it's
concentrated in the soviet uh dominated
angola government
um
and uh
we certainly got involved in the congo
got
involved getting
had a big african practice uh working
with reagan foreign policy and bush
foreign policy uh objectives in africa
again in the course of the last five
years a lot of this has been distorted
and we'll talk about this some i'm sure
today it's in my book as well
um where
the
uh woke left for one of a better term
decided that they were just going to
declare
that i was pro-russian
pro-putin
and uh
never with any facts i mean because i
represented a an oligarch uh in russia
that became tantamount to anything and
everything for my whole career and uh
and he was an oligarch that we were not
doing things in russia on
um although he was concerned with
bringing some changes to russia as well
and i get into that in the book
so it means over the course of
of the last 20 years i got involved in
ukraine
uh
i mean i thought ukraine was a very
important country
uh the soviet well the russians were
trying to uh
to
force ukraine to not become part of
europe i thought ukraine should be a
part of your uh elected a government
that
was from eastern ukraine so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]